con carnet y una sonrisa encubierta un
recuerdo de una jornada histórica en la
que ellos el personal de salud de
primera línea de batalla contra el cob y
19 son los protagonistas pero comenzó en
lima la capital su vacunación contra el
cob y de 19 en una etapa inicial que
tiene como objetivo inocular a un millón
de personas entre profesionales
sanitarios militares y policías me
parecía muy lejos
la vacuna para realizar este proceso
y me parece un sueño de qué
y hasta en la vacuna y que nos estemos
comienza un proceso que llena de
esperanza el segundo país de américa con
la mayor tasa de mortalidad por cada
100.000 habitantes por el nuevo
coronavirus sólo superado por eeuu los
lotes de la vacuna ya partieron fuera de
lima a otras regiones como huánuco una
de las zonas más castigadas por el
hobbit 19 en el horizonte una siguiente
fase para vacunar a 5,3 millones de
adultos mayores con enfermedades
preexistentes se ha empezado por vacunar
a nivel nacional todos los
establecimientos que cuentan con una
unidad de cuidados intensivos todo el
personal asistencial del establecimiento
el que tiene que ver con contacto
directo con los pacientes se vacuna
primero hay alivio por el comienzo de la
vacunación siendo perú el sexto país de
sudamérica en dar inicio a este proceso
la mala noticia llega desde la
asociación nacional de periodistas de
perú que afirma que en 10 meses
108 reporteros han perdido la vida a
causa del cover 19 según ellos la cifra
más alta en el mundo